nbc news dropping a dime on the
president with a new expose and it is a
doozy
biden is annoyed that his staff is
always rushing to correct his gaffes
because it undermines his credibility
and his authenticity the president also
reportedly frustrated with how badly his
administration is being run no kidding
and he says his fellow democrats do not
defend him enough in the media
even though it's overwhelmingly liberal
jessica
media is comprised entirely almost of
democrats and almost always they're
defending joe biden what does that say
when you have the president complaining
about a lack of defense
every president complains about their
coverage
it's just the way it goes should never
complain they should be i'll let them
know stop complaining
yesterday the inflation conversation the
gas prices i think turn took a very
serious turn with janet yellen giving an
interview where she said that she was
wrong about what was going to happen
with inflation and now
steve ratner and larry summers both
together with the same point about the
spending bill and it's interesting
because there's a division now amongst
democrats who one side feels like we
should just acknowledge that the
american rescue act had this effect that
we still stand by it as policy and that
the country needed it at this time but
that something was done wrong and then
the white house is more dug in on the
i'm not going to admit anything and
it'll be really interesting going
forward to see how candidates are taking
this because it's going to be very split
in purple districts you're going to see
people saying i voted for this because i
thought it was the right thing to do it
has had this negative effect and we need
to watch what we do in terms of big
spending bills going forward in the last
two years before the next general
election i that didn't answer your
question
i'm glad i got it out there it's okay
get it off your chest judge you know you
notice this nbc report and they're not
talking about joe solving problems with
gas prices no new solutions on inflation
he's just lashing out at everybody what
does that tell you
well i i think that what it tells me is
he's not he's not really in control i
mean what i want to know is who keeps
correcting him joe why don't you find
out who's correcting you and then let
the person go if you're upset with them
for correcting everything that you're
saying but if you're so clueless you
don't know who's correcting you then you
pretty much deserve what you got um i
think that one of the problems is that
you know no one forget about people
going on television to support them they
don't even want them in their district
yeah i mean and you know this guy's got
the lowest presidential approving
approval ratings ever ever am i wrong i
think it's ever no one's beating them no
he's so he just beat his way to the
bottom and you know what no one's worked
harder you can beat your way to the
bottom with the best of them don't you
greg you sick
nothing but red flags all right it's
only one um i i like the fact that he
claims he he's not getting enough credit
it's like yeah sure gas prices are so
high but that means you can spend more
time at home with your family and think
of all the money you save on travel mugs
and bumper stickers to continue the car
analogy
we were sold a lemon and if a lemon
could talk it would tell you it's your
fault for buying him but it's not the
voters fault at all because they were
sold the lemon under false pretenses
right they rolled back the odometer
right you know they gave it a new paint
job put on some new rims here's joe just
like new except he's a moderate just
like old joe he's great for road trips
and unifying and then it turns out
everything was a con job the irony of
this whole thing is that trump got
blamed for being a salesman right when
basically all he was trying to do was
sell himself and then when he became
president sell america to the world that
was his job biden was the sale of the
century a con job orchestrated by the
far left in order to get him in so they
could fill him with their progressive
agenda it's a it's probably one of the
greatest uh bait and switches in
political history and we're alive to see
it it is a very nice time to be alive
shannon when you read this nbc news
report and you see this one line where
he says he doesn't like how his
administration is being run
he's the chief executive he's the one
running the administration he can change
and fire and do whatever he wants and
apparently that's how the american
people feel as well because in all the
most recent rounds of polling he is down
double ditch with people who voted for
him young voters black voters latino
voters independents like this is going
to be a nightmare for him if he doesn't
turn around something before the
midterms the economy everybody now
admits including his advisors is not
going to get better before it gets worse
and even with this baby formula thing
those are the kinds of things that
people vote on filling up their gas tank
putting food on the table now today
they're saying even with these shipments
coming in the wall street journal says
the shortage is actually going to get
worse on baby formula and it will take
us through months and no possibilities
fix that
don't even get started on my hot pockets
no popcorn don't use shortage i fill up
my gasoline with baby formula that's how
bad it is
yes so when the engine gets hot though i
have popcorn and i have baby formula in
my gasket at the same time at the same
time all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else